字幕: Shimajiri Michiaki
校正: Chie Kosuga
今日は新しい働き方というようなことを
お話したいと思います
私はベンチャーキャピタリストなんですけれども
ベンチャーキャピタリストっていうのが
どういう仕事をしているか
分からないと思うんですけれども
起業家を応援をして会社を立ち上げる
事業を立ち上げるという
仕事をさせてもらってます
働くって 学校を卒業して
働くっていったら みなさん
どういうことを考えますかね？
働く
どうですか高校生の方
だいだいですね この働くっていうのは
皆さんひょっとすると
会社に勤めるということを
想像すると思うんですね
ここで話の最初に働くってのに２種類あるなということを
ちょっと説明をしておきたいと思います
働くっていうのは 学校を卒業して
会社勤めをする すなわち
時間を会社に売るんですね
その契約をやって働くことになります
組織に労働時間を売る
働き方っていうのがあります
これは給料をもらいまして
労働契約をやって 法律で守られています
職務の分担があります
一方で われわれが見ていきたい
働き方っていうのは
会社に時間を売ることではなくて
事業を実現するっていうことも
もともと働くって意味だったんじゃないですかね
例えば 狩猟時代 農耕時代 それから商業時代
何かを実現することが働くことであったのに
我々がいつのまにやら
会社に時間を売るということを
働くことだというふうに
見るようになったんじゃないでしょうか
それをですね ジョブシーカー
職を探すことをジョブシークといいますけれども
ジョブシーカーと
それとその仕事を作っていく側
ジョブメーカーといいますけれども
世の中にもしジョブシーカーばかり
すなわち 大学を卒業して高校卒業して
就職することばかり考える人たち
ばっかりの世の中だったとしたら
これは仕事を作る側の仕事が
雇う側も必要なわけですね
私のことにちょっと話を戻したいと
思うんですけれども
私は実はですね1945年に
戦後 戦争が[終わった年]ですね
12月に南海大地震がありまして
そこで津波がありましてですね
何百人もの人が亡くなりました
四国でですね それから紀伊半島で
私の母親の
母親はちょうどですね 小学校4年生で
それで
父親をですねこの津波で
亡くしました
私は
母は高校卒業して結婚しまして
津波の12年後ですけれども
私は四国の
徳島県海部郡海南町字馬の谷48の1
というですね
非常に長い住所で生まれました
とにかくど田舎ですね
それから中学校のときには
私は水泳の選手になりまして
これも一番真ん中にいるのが私ですけれども
全国大会を目指しましたけれども
県では優勝したんですけれども
全国大会に行けず挫折しました
私は一体自分は誰なのだろうかと
一所懸命私は
水泳の選手になろうと思って
努力してたんですけれども
水泳の選手になれなくて
それで 受験校に行きました
町に医者という職業しかなかったので
私は医者を目指しまして
勉強しましたけど ２年浪人をして
それで結局奨学金で経済学部に
入ることになりました
ところがですね
私は医者になるつもりでずっといたのに
結局高校時代ですね
とりあえずは高校時代の友達のところに
大学に入って行ってみたら
シェイクスピア研究会というところにいたので
それでそこに入って演出家になることになりました
これは当時私がシェイクスピア劇を演出した
テンペストという芝居なんですけれども
六本木で上演ができて非常に大成功でした
私もですね ちょっと学生芝居では
有名になりましたので
よし演出家になろうということで意気揚々と
先輩を頼っていきますと
先輩がいうにはですね
君はお金持ちの家の息子なのかと
そうでないと演劇なんてやってられないよ
というふうに言われて
いやとんでもありません
徳島県海部郡海南町字馬の谷48の1です
と言うと
それはやめた方がいい
ということでですね
演劇の道を挫折して 諦めることにしました
結局自分はいったい誰なんだろうと
もう23才になってましたね
とりあえず経済学を勉強してみようと
経済学部に入りましたのでね
友達と経済学の勉強をして
当時台本を一所懸命読んでいたので
経済学の本を読むとですね
字がこう浮いて読める感じ
それぐらい本を読むのが得意になっていて
そこで私が感じたのは
まず世の中にはジョブシーカーと
ジョブメーカーがいるなということです
産業革命の後 工業革命があって
20世紀ですね
これは会社がいっぱいできて
それでそこに勤める人が
世の中必要だったわけですね
ジョブシーカーがいっぱい
教育によって生み出される
という時代から
21世紀 もう15年経ってますけれども
ジョブメーカー 情報革命ですね
いろんな人がいろんなことを
できるような環境に
ガラッと変わっていると
あとですね
経済学で学んだのは いくら立派な
社会貢献活動もですね
ちゃんと事業化しないと
歴史の中で多くの人に行き渡らないと
結局は
どんな作業も事業化をきちっとしないと
人に迷惑を結局かけてしまうと
自己満足の活動になってしまう
ということを学びました
その中でですね私は
1982年
あのベルリンの壁が崩壊する
７年前ですけれども
お隣の中国は当時12億人の
人口だって言っていたんですね
その12億人の人口のうちの半分の６億人が
もし計画経済 共産経済から
資本主義経済にもし
移行しなきゃいけなくなったら
私はもう移行するしかないという風に
経済学の本を読んだら
見えたわけですけれども
そうすると
半分の６億人割る １社あたり千人
会社が採用するとすると
６億人を千で割ったら
そうですね 60万ですね
60万社がいきなりですね
この世界史の中で
起業しなければいけなくなってくると
ということはですね
これは私が生きている内にですね
起業ビッグバンがくるんじゃないかと
いうふうに
私は思いましてですね
それで これはベンチャーキャピタリスト
すなわち 会社を立ち上げるのを
手伝う仕事がいいんじゃないかと
いうふうに思ったんですね
ところがですね
ベンチャーキャピタルの先輩に
話を聞きに行ったらですね
キミは何を考えているんだと
この東西冷戦構造の真っ只中
もっと現実的な事を考えなさいと
経済学部の学生なんでしょう
ということで
えらい怒られました
とにかくですね私は
シリコンバレー行ってみようということで
シリコンバレーへ行ってみました
そこで学生の身分ながらですね
いろいろとコンコンコンと
I came from Japan. と
I'd like to become a venture capitalist. と
Do I have to get MBA? と
Not necessary. と
これは受験で勉強した「部分否定」だなと
What is important to become
a venture capitalist? というふうに言いますとですね
human understanding という単語が
聞こえてきました
human understanding と言えばですよ
シェイクスピアですね
ここは過去完了だなと
I had directed Shakespeare drama
in university. と言いますとですね
That's it! とこうきたわけですね
これは受験的に
（拍手）
ありがとうございます
これって予備校で学んだ口語で
「その通り」という意味ですね
よしっ これでベンチャーキャピタルになろうと思って
日本に戻ってですね 会社に入ったわけです
これがですね
結局
会社にはいったんですけれども
ベンチャーキャピタリストってのは本来
会社を育てる仕事なわけですね
にも関わらずですね わたしは
ベンチャーキャピタリストになるんじゃなくて
ベンチャーキャピタル会社に入ったんですね
結局はベンチャーキャピタル会社に
就職をしましたので
ジョブシーカーとして
ベンチャーキャピタル事務所に入ったんですね
そうするとですね
命令が全部人事異動で決まっているんですよ
この部署にあんたは入れと
そこでこういう風な仕事をやれと
今日はこうしろ今週はこうしろ
来月はそうしろ
組織人だったら当然のことですよね
PDCAで管理されながら
ところがですね
とにかく給料が毎月
できてもできなくてもちゃんと入ってくると
これいいなぁ という風に思いまして
それで東京で仕事をした後
北海道に転勤をすることになりました
北海道ではですね
ほとんど上場会社がない原野のような場所で
北の 一番北なんですね北海道って
涼しくって素晴らしいところなんですけれども
上場会社がない
この上場会社がないこの北海道から
上場会社を出さなきゃと
いうことでですね
いろんな企業家の人と
とにかく毎日毎晩話をしてまして
スーパーフクハラさんだとか
いろんなところに投資をして
共成レンテムさんとか
投資をしまして
成功するんですけれども
そん中で 1991年ちょうど日本がバブルに
湧いてたときですけれども
名称すら当時は一般的でなかったのですけれども
老人介護
医療とか福祉とか保険とか
こういう単語は一般的だったんだけれども
介護という単語は新聞にも出てなかったんですよね
その介護っていう時代が
高齢化社会がやってくるんだから
高齢者の人たちを
介護するサービスっていうのが
一大産業になるだろう
というふうなことを思いましてですね
まだ従業員が1人 社長と合わせて2人でやっていた
ジャパンケアサービスという会社に投資をしました
これを調整するのに
ものすごい大変な思いをしました
なぜならば 単語がないので説明にならないんですね
とにかく未知のフロンティアなので
フロンティア分野には実績がありませんね
それからデータがないんですよ その業界の
それから経験者がいない
だから誰に聞いてもですね
分からん 訳分からないと
これから産業ができていって 雇用が発生して
新しい商品が市場に投入されて
新しい時代ができていくという
一番最初のところなので
それを自分たちでやっていこうというときに
この組織を説得するのが大変
社内調整で手間取りました
その結果
わたしはまた自分は誰なんだろうという
ことなんですけれども
働きすぎてですね 胸膜炎になっちゃって
それで 創成川の近くの病院に
１カ月入院することになりました
33歳の年ですね
よかれと思って
未来のために投資をしようとするのに
みんな私のことをですね
なんでそんなわざわざ変わったことをするんだと
いう風なことを
言われましてですね
変人扱いされてしまうと
しかし 非常に業績がよろしかったので 私は
北海道の投資先が次々と上場することになりまして
７年半を経てですね
東京に転勤しました
さて東京に転勤して私が
どんな産業に目をつけたでしょうか
IT!
当たった人は何も出ないですね
私が注目したのはですね
コスプレですね
日本のアニメですね
これを世界に出していこうということで
まだ萌系という単語がなかったんですよ
1995年当時はね
これも従業員が社長と奥さんと 2人でやっている
会社に通ってですね
よしこれを一つ産業化していこう
いいぞということでやったら
組織の中でまた調整しなきゃいけないんですよね
データがない これも必死で調整をしてですね
審査部員をコスプレパーティーに連れて
ネクタイをして連れて行くとですね
もう会場全部コスプレですよ
そこにネクタイをしめてスミマセンという感じで
すごいなぁみたいな
こんな感じで入っていきましてですね
それで投資をさせてもらったんですけれども
それがですね
やっぱり会社の中で帰り際に
おまえは何てところに投資しようとするんだと
当時言われましてですね
それでいつも私は変わり者扱いを受けるという
サラリーマン時代の前半だったですね
もう35歳になっていました
ところがですね
組織の中でやった仕事が
次々と介護サービスも萌系も
全部上場してですね
組織の中で異端者と言われるような
あいつはちょっと変わっているヤツなんだ
ということですね
自分が誰なんだろうかと
もう38歳にもなっていましたけれども
思い直して見ましたけれども
とにかくですね
古い組織というものはですね
その変化 時代の変化ですね
時代の変化というものを
どう感じます？
リスクと感じるんですよ
なんかこう自分の組織が
変わっちまうんじゃないかっていうことでですね
組織が変わらないようにということで
時代が変化するのを 組織はですね
一緒にリスクマネージメントっていうことで
リスクと感じるんですね
ところが 個人はですね
時代が変化する 特に若者は
時代の変化こそが opportunity
機会ですよね
だから 組織ではなくてですね
個人の創造性こそが
重要なんじゃないかと
いうことで私は
会社組織を離れてですね
独立ベンチャーキャピタル事務所を作ろうということで
日本で初めてですね
個人でその代表をやる
ベンチャーキャピタルファンドっていうのを作りまして
自分の判断で投資をしていこうということを
考えたわけです ところがですね
実際組織を離れてですよ
14年間も結局勤めていましたけれども
離れたらどんな感じがするかって言うとですね
まあ非常に居心地が悪いんですけれども
パンツをはかないでズボンをはいている感じ
はいて歩いてる感じ
非常にこう気持ちが悪いですね
そんなような感じで
独立するってこんなことなのか ということを
自分自身でも体験をしまして
歩きました
堀場製作所の堀場さんに この話をしたところですね
堀場さんに説明したらですね
断られるのではないかなと
スタートアップにしか投資をしませんと
ない産業に投資をしますと
いうことを言ったらですね
堀部さんは「ふーん ふーん」
10分位聞いてて
「ほれやっ！」と言ったんですね
びっくりしたんですけれども
非常に勇気をもらいまして
それで創業投資に邁進することになります
DeNAに投資をしたのも
そういうファンドで投資をしまして
最初立ち上がりのところはシステム発注で大変苦労した
南場智子社長ですけれども
これはDeNAが一千億企業になりましてですね
グラフを見ていただくと
一千億企業なんですけれども
横浜ベイスターズを買ったのは 上場のですね
もう5年ぐらいたった後なんですね
私が投資をしましたのはIPOの前
この前のあの部分をですね
拡大するとこんな感じです
もう最初の3年間はずっと赤字
立ち上がりのところはとにかく
準備準備準備準備なんで
準備中ということは売上が立たないから
赤字になるわけですね
3年間苦労して結局私
大金持ちになっちゃってですね
アインファーマシーズの大谷社長なんかからですね
厳しいアドバイスももらっていたんですけれども
なんと銀座に寿司屋を持つことができたんですね
ありがとうございます
（拍手）
その税金をですね
結局私はお世話になったのはやっぱり田舎なので
東京じゃなくて田舎に納付しようということで
住民票を移しましてですね
数千万円の税金を田舎に納付いたしました
それであの駅前にですね
高校生が雨宿りができる建物が
できたわけなんですけれども
東京に戻ってきて
これをもう少し制度化できないかなと
いうことでですね
日経新聞さんの
夕刊にコラムを書きましてですね
それがの現在の日本のふるさと納税に
なったということでございます
（拍手）
結局私もですねジョブシーカー
ジョブメーカーということを考えると
教育っていうものが実際日本の教育は
全部その就職のためのジョブシーカー向けの
教育だなぁということでですね
ジョブメーカー向けの教育を
子どもたちにやってあげたいなということを思いまして
ゼロから始められる学園祭での起業体験プログラム
ていうのを
考えてですね プログラム化しました
チームを作って
事業計画作って それで会社を起こして
事業の準備を 資本を集めて
事業の準備をやりまして
販売をやりましてですね
それで決算書を作って
株主総会をやって解散をすると 利益分配するというのを
ちゃんと会社のルールでやってみるということですね
子どもたちにですねよく言うのは
花を育てるみたいなもんだよと
種は皆さん企業家の人たちですね
種が根を張って
それは会社組織をつくることですけれども
資本を集めて
志をもって芽を出して それで森の中で
枝を張り葉っぱを茂らせて探索していきます
ここかな ここかなみたいな感じですね
葉っぱが茂らせてきて ここだぞといいところで
太陽の光が 機会ですね 事業の機会ですね
それでここだったらいいなというところに
主力商品の花を咲かせます
蜜を出してですね
顧客であるミツバチに来てもらって それで受粉をして
そこでできるのが果実
すなわち利益ですね こういうことを体験をする
さしてあげようということですね
さて 皆さんの働き方はどうでしょうかと
いうことですね
結論のところですけれど
あなたは組織人なんでしょうか
それとも自立した個人なんでしょうか
ジョブメーカーなんでしょうか
ジョブシーカーなんでしょうか
常に時代というものは必ず
音をたてて変わっていきます
いろんな事件が起こりますよね
毎週のように
そん中でわれわれは生きていかなきゃいけない
21世紀に生きていく成功のヒントをちょっと
お話したいと思いますけど
まず1つ目は まだ解けてはいない未来のですね
その変化を機会としてしっかり捉えるということ
2つ目はですね 束縛から解放されるということ
特に20世紀的な組織の束縛ですね
自由に自立精神をもって
それで勇気で行動してですね
変人扱いをだいたい受けます
だけれどもそれに屈しないで
試行錯誤で忍耐をもって実行すると
それで傲慢を下げてジョブメーカーの視点でやれば
人生いつかどこかでですね必ず実を結ぶ日が
私はやってくるんじゃないかと思うんですね
私の好きな言葉をちょっと紹介しておきますけれども
水のようにいきいきと
水のように力づよく
水のようにこだわらず
ということです
とにかく21世紀の人類のですね
働き方これは組織人の人も
それから個人もですね
あらゆる20世紀のですね 20世紀ってのは
そういう世紀だったんです
従属的組織からですね
精神的に皆が自立して
それで起業家精神で考えて行動して
それで試行錯誤で新しい平和な社会をつくって
大変だけれども 幸せな人生に
挑戦をしていくということが
重要なんじゃないか
という風に思います
最後にですね
私の母の おじいちゃんですね
私は見たことも話した事もないんですけれども
おじいちゃんが死んだときにですね
津波の時に 全世界からいろんなものを
送ってもらったそうで
本当にこの場を借りてですね
お礼を言いたいと思います
それからたまたまですね
本当につい数日前のことですけれども
スタートアップを愛したですね
堀場製作所の創業者
堀場雅夫さんがですねお亡くなりになりまして
本当に私の心の支えだったのですけれども
彼の意志を継いで 頑張って私も
起業家をこれからも応援をしていきたいと思います
ありがとうございます
（拍手）